Victor is on Twitter you can follow me
there if you dare at Dave Ramsey about
734 thousand of you do give or take and
sometimes some of you are mad but that's
okay that's part of how life works and
it's part of the beauty of Twitter it
allows some of you have courage where
otherwise you would not have any so um
that digital courage is magical fairy
dust I'll just tell you anyway Victor
says he's not he's not being smart he
has a legitimate question I think sorta
how would you respond to someone that
said the economy would suffer if
everyone was smart with money I would
try not to hang out with them they're a
fool they have a vow they have a
worldview that says that the only way
that people win with money is to do harm
to someone that's what that
presupposition is in other words if
everyone was smart with money then no
one would prosper just what that fool is
saying they're a fool bye-bye fool I
mean a biblical definition of a fool
which is a fool by the way so what am I
saying I'm saying the economy prospers
more when people are smart with money
than when they are dumb with money and
so the smarter we were with money the
more the economy would grow because
guess what causes the economy to grow
people being wealthy versus people being
poor what causes you to be wealthy being
smart with money if you're smart with
money you become wealthy if more people
were smarter with money more people
would be wealthy and when the economy
would grow more wealthy people spend
more and do more in the economy than
poor people do in terms of the actual
numbers of dollars that are moved around
and so the smarter we all are with our
money the better it is for the economy
so the presupposition of the person's
question in other words is that the only
way that people win with money is if
they do harm to someone
and that's someone that doesn't know how
life works
and it wouldn't be someone I'd want to
hang around with much rabbi Daniel lapin
wrote the book thou shalt prosper
it's a great book about why Jewish
people have a tendency to prosper and
one of the things he talks about it
there is that when you do good for
others in the marketplace they give you
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces on them only jerks only
jerks and crooks succeed no
statistically it's not true plus common
sense if you have any would tell you
that common sense isn't common amour
that's why we have this show so here's
how it works let's think about it Joe
owns a car repair place and Joe rips you
off you're going to get your car fixed
and he screws you over so are you going
to go back to Joe no not unless you're
an idiot
are you going to tell all your friends
not to go to Joe yes Joe will not
succeed why because Joe is a crook and
the word gets out on a crook
occasionally they find new bait for
their little trap but by and large their
old customers don't come back and they
don't send their friends which is where
most customers come from by the way in
business most of you found this show or
bought one of my books or went to one of
our classes or one of our events because
a friend told you it was good not
because that your friend told you I was
a crook Oh Joe says he's a crook let's
go to Dave's thing no that's not how
that works right so if you go get your
car fixed and Joe does a good job he's
kind to you and you know makes a profit
on the transaction but treats you fairly
and you feel like you got a good deal
when your car got repaired because it
was actually freakin repaired then what
do you do next time your car breaks you
go back to Joe Oh what do you do when
your friend says oh my car broke do you
know anybody you say hey Joe's
trustworthy go see Joe you go to a
restaurant the restaurant sucks do you
tell your friends go over there and eat
you'll get food poisoning no you don't
do that
you tell your friends to stay away from
the place it's a dump it's a dive it's
bad news the service is horrible how
many times have you told your friends
not to go see a movie not to read a book
not to do business at such-and-such a
company because they mistreated you and
how many times do you not go back the
only reason you would go back as if
you're psychologically damaged why would
you go back you don't go back and so
good people that do good work are the
ones that prosper stupid the crooks
don't prosper they don't all they do on
the short-term and occasionally you hear
them in the news they rip somebody off
and they make the news or whatever but
by-and-large over the scope of our
economy the people that prosper are the
ones that serve and that do good things
for people this is why we should not
vilify wealthy people 88% of America's
millionaires are first-generation rich
they started with nothing they served
someone they helped someone in some way
and they helped a whole bunch of people
over a long period of time thus they
became wealthy starting from nothing
that's called being successful we should
teach our children to serve people and
help people and do it in mass and the
blessings are you get certificates of
appreciation with presidents faces on
them if you work in a fine restaurant
with a white tablecloth and you serve
someone what do you get a tip on a nice
tip it's how that works isn't it do you
feel bad if you leave someone a tip
towards that person no they didn't rip
you off they served you you gladly share
some of your money to share your
appreciation with them that's profit
that's how profit works so let's go back
to the question how do you respond to
someone that said that the economy would
suffer if everyone was smart with money
if you're smart with money you get out
of debt thus you have more money to give
and more money to save and if you're out
of debt and on a plan and you're smart
with money and you avoid ripoff bad
products like credit cards and whole
life policies and car leases
and you get to keep more of your money
because you're smart with money do you
think that if everybody did that that
they would not function in the economy
no there's nothing about being smart
with car being smart with money that
causes you to be a hermit I spend more
money now I spend more money on a trip
now than I used to make in a year
so I mean I don't spend less money
because I became wealthy I spend more
money because I became wealthy I'm not
irresponsible or flashy or anything else
some say I am but I definitely don't
dress flashy Sharon tells me that every
morning so but you know the deal is you
just have to understand how wealth
really works and how it enter were how
it is interwove n't into the economy and
then you realize how victim based and
this you know I grew up with people like
this I said stuff like little man can't
get ahead o the little man the little
man can't get ahead well get out of
somebody fix my life because I can't fix
my own life
little man can't get ahead this guy's
got the spirit of Eeyore
it's just spirit animal ee or little man
can't get ahead is a bunch of political
crap little man can't get ahead because
you got it between your stew to stinking
ears that said you can't get ahead all
good a hood I grew up listen I grew up
redneck hillbilly shut up and I've been
a millionaire twice I'm so dumb I had to
do it twice don't tell me it can't be
done of course it can be done of course
it can be done I don't care what your
sex is what your race is what your
background is some of us have more to
overcome than others some of us are
smarter than others a lot of people
smarter than me my GPA will prove that
but I'll work a bunch of them so that'll
that'll fix that and by the way works a
choice it's a choice it's a surefire
money-making scheme so how do I respond
to someone that says the economy would
suffer if everyone was smart with money
I probably wouldn't I would probably
just
put a label across their forehead that
said fool and I probably just not spend
a lot of time with them because if you
hang out with fools you know what you
become just like them hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind